hey don't ask me how my night was last
night how was your night last night go
it was ok I camped out on on stockton
street in san francisco for the new
iphone mm-hmm nice but you know that
because you cut me in line and got yours
first they're waking up that at
reasonable hour having breakfast with
your family yep well there are
privileges to being part of the press
and actually uh god I got to the front
of the line they're like come on in yeah
I think might even because you were
wearing my shirt yeah your shirt did
help thank you for that she was earlier
and I had a fleece on with nothing on
underneath free show for the Apple
people and but we thought I also want to
point out that as soon as I sat down and
you're very comfortable hammock yeah
somebody came along and gave me this
which is not the phone that's inside
this nauseating the green case but the
case itself and you know I think I'm
going to take it off because I sort of
like the way I know you should leave I
man it's ribbed for her pleasure it's my
phone not her phone good point yeah you
went with white also yeah the white so
yeah I don't know quite why I went with
the white it was sort of an impulse
decision the white is only available in
the 16 gig model and I was kind of
waffling I was like I don't think I
really need 16 gigs especially with apps
like pandora which let me you know we're
going to let me stream all the music i
want there's a strong argument for
getting the eight gig model yeah i want
the white cool i mean actually I've been
carrying this nokia e71 recently which
will be reviewing soon but it just made
me really in love with a white phone I
think it's really elegant and i think
that the iphone looks great in white
especially because i can't imagine i
hate saying this really actually but I
mean the iphone white looks more like a
classic ipod it is it's the original
color from apple and so that's kind of I
mean it's kind of awesome it's amazing
that we're saying it's the classic ipod
color because you think of these things
is pretty high tech and new but but no
it's true i think and i think apple is
kind of defined white as their colors so
you look at this and you're like yeah
that's an apple product there's no
question about it um I've been pretty
impressed by the phone so far although I
have to say it took me half the day to
get this thing activated the in-store
activation process there's a little bit
of a glitch early on and
and there were some problems with the
servers that meant it just I just kept
trying to connect and connect through
itunes did you have that experience too
yeah it was pretty it was pretty
frustrating and meanwhile I'm sitting
there trying to get my phone to work and
Stephen Lee be who's our new columnist
is sitting right behind me with the
apple rep with him saying oh and here
you go it's already activated and I was
just like fish shakings like I slept on
the street I have this thing plugged
into my computer I'm really tired and
it's not working and she's like oh look
at all the things you can do so it
really is who you know isn't it I
amazingly yes well well now that it's
working i see your iphone is working
you've got some apps on their app store
baby i love it and you know this is this
is what's 3g fine gps fine app store
important yeah that is the real big deal
i totally agree and actually the ironic
thing is you don't need an iphone 3g to
do that you just need a 2 point 0
operating system which is now available
to any iphone or ipod touch user yep and
that's kind of cool I think it's great i
mean what this shows is you know this is
the start of a platform war and this is
something that's been happening in pcs
and computers for a long time but now
you're seeing in phones and this is the
first legitimate salvo saying okay you
know what it's not the hardware it's the
software this is something that nokia
has been saying for a long time but
people have largely ignored them but now
we see another company another major
company with a large distribution of
handsets out in the marketplace saying
you know what yeah you're right we do
need to open up this development
platform and actually let some people
make some make some apps for it you're
absolutely right I wouldn't downplay the
importance of 3g and gps though because
the addition of those two features for
me transforms this from you know sort of
a an entry-level starter phone to a true
smartphone I mean this is now actually
very competitive with other smartphones
on the market because it's got that fast
data it's got that ability to locate us
in the world through GPS and now I'm
going to argue with you and disagree and
say no the smartphone is not about 3g
and gps i think the smartphone's about
the about the apps and that's why the
App Store so important for this well you
know what we can we can agree to
disagree on this one because this phone
has it all and you know this
this thing about this phone is the
pricing when you say the pricing is very
smart actually you can buy it for 200
bucks now for the eight gig version or
300 bucks for the 16 gig version fancy
that's so that's a really easy to
swallow price now the thing is that the
trade-off is you have to pay a little
bit more for the data plan I think 70
bucks a month is the cheapest you're
going to get out of there and the
charger extra or text messaging which
which I think that's annoying it's
really student so a two-year contract at
70 bucks a month or more I mean you're
going to wind up paying for this phone a
question shut I think I think for a lot
of people that this is a really good
deal well clearly we thought it was
worth it
you